تعرف مدينه القاهره بماضيها العريق لكن
الحكومه المصريه تتطلع الان لمستقبل جديد
ولربما عاصمه جديده كشف عن خطط هذه
المدينه في مؤتمر التنميه الاقتصاديه بمصر
من قبل المسؤولين في الدوله ومطورين لها
في دبي ويكلف المشروع 45 مليار دولار على
مدى ست
سنوات احب ان اعمل على مشاريع كبيره في
مساحات
واسعه اما محمد العبار فهو معروف بمشاريعه
كبيره اذ انه الرجل وراء اطول مبدا في
العالم برج خليفه يتوقع بناء هذه المدينه
الجديده التي لم تطلق عليها تسميه رسميه
بعد في شرق القاهره على امل استدراج
الشعبي بعيدا عن ازدحام وفوضى العاصمه
ويؤكد العبار ان المدينه الجديده ستفعل
ذلك ستكون اكبر من واشنطن بعشره اضعاف لذا
ستستوعب ما يقرب من مليوني نسمه واما
الوديان والتي ستكون بمنتهى الجمال فتعادل
اربعه الى خمسه اضعاف حجم حديقه هاي وبعد
ذلك سنوفر كل وسائل الراحه التي تضمن جعل
الشعب سعيدا ومبتسما نحن نعمل على هذا
نهارا
وليلا كما ان الحكومه المصريه ستعمل بلا
توقف اذ ان هناك حاجه لمشاريع البنيه
التحتيه فمن غير التقدم الاقتصادي هناك
خطر لحصول المزيد من الاضطرابات السياسيه
الطموح هنا كبير واذا سارت الامور وفقا
للخطه فقد يغير هذا مدينه القاهره
للابد امير دفتي cnn شارم
شيخ